how do you think the internet will
evolve the next five years Matthew of
London you know I really don't know i
mean the internet is definitely perhaps
the the invention of the development
which has changed my life with the
computer more than almost anything else
I can think I may I really am irritated
that it came so late in my life and that
I wasn't brought up to really be a
techie and really with it and fluent in
internet and modern computer technology
and I just got too much to do to become
really fluent in this area but i think
the the big the big breakthrough to some
extent may already have been the way in
which individuals have been franchised
and able to make programs so that young
people can make a film and make it
available on the internet and that
Google can find it is incredible that in
seconds you can find material on the
internet that is unbelievable I mean
like that has definitely change my life
now because I may give a lot of lectures
and if I want some information I can get
it very rapidly from things like
Wikipedia Wikipedia has also been a
massive breakthrough in the sense that
individuals all over the world can
altruistically contribute to the global
cache of information that's out there
and in the sciences and mathematics is
pretty reliable and we have checks the
scientists that we know and when I look
at websites where I want some
information that I know move it it's
it's very very good I mean in political
situations and elders they start but
once i think this contentious ones
there's more of a problem but not in not
really much in the sciences and so that
aspect has been tremendous and I my view
is what I'm doing with my GF set program
global educational out
reach for science engineering technology
technology geo set I'm trying to
encourage individuals and organizations
teaching education institutions all over
the world to contribute to a global
cache of educational material that
teachers can utilize either directly or
help them to keep their sort of teach
science a lot as as well as possible and
so also to capture the genius of our
teachers who when they retire there
they're sort of expertise goes with them
we can now capture the best teachers for
posterity and it gives them immortality
so it's geo ceos ET dot info pragya set
into google you'll find us and not only
that our students are making programs
and there's going on to their CVS we
revolutionized the resume because our
students are recording little
presentations five-minute presentations
on their research or five minutes on
their project or five minutes on
whatever interests them and then we put
the URL into their reference or into
their CV and that's become a really
paradigm shifting aspect of the resume
these will change things because I think
you won't be going for an interview
because people to see you on the way and
they make the decision there then pros
and cons or play more pros and cons